en diversas estaciones de abastecimiento
de combustible se formaron largas colas
de transportistas hacían filas para
tratar de abastecerse de glp que lo que
ocurrió hubo un oleaje anómalo en el
litoral peruano y esto obligó al cierre
de 40 puertos en el país y esto motivó
que se frenará la cadena de distribución
sin embargo en las últimas horas la
marina de guerra del perú ha señalado
que las condiciones se están volviendo a
la normalidad y que se realizará muy
pronto el abastecimiento de la cadena de
suministros esta tarde van a marchar en
lima los docentes del perú en realidad
es una jornada nacional de lucha de los
maestros ellos están exigiendo al
presidente pedro castillo que frene el
alto costo de lo que significa la
canasta básica que tienen que sustentar
los peruanos y que les ayude a mejorar
las condiciones laborales y salariales
también le piden que eleve al 6% el
presupuesto público para el sector de
educación
garantice el nombramiento aún no se
encuentran en el padrón estatal y que
también mejore las pensiones para los
jubilados